FEMALE SPEAKER: Chance to
enjoy some of the tunes
that we set out to set the mood.
From Barrett Strong's,
"Money"-- that's what I want--
to Pink Floyd's, "Money", to
Lady Gaga's, "Money Honey",
it's multiple generations of
music all singing the same
tune.
Money is kind of a big deal.
So that's why I'm so
excited to introduce you
to Alexa Von Tobel.
And let me read a
little bit about her
so that you can get
just as excited as I am.
So Alexa is the CEO and
founder of LearnVest,
and she's a certified
financial planner
who attended Harvard College
and Harvard Business School.
Alexa has been featured as a
financial expert in the Wall
Street Journal, The New York
Times, Fast Company, Forbes,
InStyle, Glamour,
the list goes on.
She has been recognized
in Inc's "30 Under 30".
She's just been a really,
really strong presence
in what's going to be a
great and important road.
So without further
ado, I really want
to have you meet
Alexa Von Tobel.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Hi guys.
I'm gonna stand
here if that's OK.
Hi guys.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
It's Thursday, so
I really appreciate
that everyone's coming to
hear a little bit about money.
Come in, sit down.
This is going to be
totally informal,
and here's the goal of today.
When you leave
here in one hour, I
want to make sure that
you've learned everything
that you need to about money.
Ask questions.
Stop me.
I'm in middle of
actually my book tour,
so "Financially
Fearless" is our book.
It's a New York
Times bestseller.
It's actually number one on
Wall Street Journal on business.
So that's pretty exciting.
It came out about now 12
days ago, 15 days ago.
And so we've been going around
the country giving this talk.
I actually gave it to
the Google in New York.
I'm going to the
Google in Beverly Hills
after this and a bunch of other
companies and organizations.
So I've done it a lot.
You're going to have questions.
Ask them.
And I'm going to stay and
sit up here at the end
and actually ask
one on one questions
if you wanna take the
time to do something
that's really specific to you.
So 10 seconds on me.
I grew up in Florida,
I went to Harvard.
Went back to Wall St-- to Morgan
Stanley and worked as a trader
on the prop-desk.
Went back to Harvard Business
School in the fall 2008.
Won a big business
plan competition
and ultimately dropped out.
I think we were in the heart
of the worst recession in 81
years, and I was literally
customer number one.
You guys are really
great product people.
I literally didn't know what
to do with my own finances.
I was young, I didn't
have a ton of money,
I didn't have no money.
I was trying to figure out
like, what's a credit score?
What are the things
that I need to know?
And what I found
was, it was such BS.
Literally trying to
navigate your money.
It's like, you literally
go Google tons of content.
You don't know it's updated,
you don't know if it's wrong.
I actually just had some at
the Google in New York come up
to me and actually was in tears.
And she was like,
Alexa, I really
need and want to
figure out my money.
She was like, I'm not
in a bad position.
She was like, but I spent
over eight hours trying
to find a financial expert,
finally found someone.
Took about a week to
get them on the phone.
We got on the
phone, and they want
to charge me like
a $3,000 retainer,
and then I have to
commit that I wanna
work with them for over a year.
She was like, and I don't
have thousands of dollars
to spend to figure out my money.
And the bottom line is, I was
like, why isn't there a way
to make people feel
great about money?
To make it extremely accessible,
and frankly, affordable.
And I'm going to share some
really important stuff.
But the goal of today is for
you to walk out feeling smarter.
I'm really psyched that
we got you guys books.
And without further
ado, we'll get started.
So first, what is LearnVest?
We've raised $45 million.
We're now one of the
leading and fastest growing
online financial planning
companies in the whole country.
We raise money from
Excel Venture Partners.
We actually just closed a big
round of another $20 million.
We're located in New York City.
We've got 110 employees.
By the end of year we'll
probably have about 180 to 200.
Plainly, simply put, we are
a program for your money.
We literally, and you guys get
product, as I said, so well.
We spent the last
three years, got
some of the best certified
financial planners.
That's the doctor
for your money.
Most people don't
even notice CFP is.
We then took a bunch of
really great product people
and technologists, and we
built really rich software
that can take any household,
whether you make $50,000,
or $500,000, And
quickly find out
what your big weak points are.
Like where you have
sort of red alerts,
and then figuring out
how you can make progress
on your money.
It's a really simple program.
The goal when I set out was that
I want to make it accessible.
It shouldn't be this
like, five day process,
where you don't
know where to go.
You don't know if
it's actual expert.
It's really expensive.
Because the message that
happens there is you then
tell yourself, I
shouldn't be doing this.
It's so complicated.
It's so hard.
Clearly I shouldn't be
taking care of my money.
When in fact, that's
not the point.
And then finally, we wanted to
make it trusted and unbiased.
So our experts at LearnVest
don't sell anything.
They just give you advice.
And my whole
family's in medicine.
And one of the
things that I started
recognizing as I was
building the company,
was you literally could
go to some experts
and they actually get
paid to sell your product.
The problem there, it's
like going to the doctor
and them getting
paid to pump you
full of antibiotics and shots,
when you're actually just sick
and need someone to
take care of you.
Next slide.
So first, follow
me and LearnVest.
We're on the tour
for the next 30 days.
But also, shoot questions to us.
We will answer them.
But we share a ton
of behind the scenes,
a ton of really important
money hacks at all times.
So, this is us.
Next.
And really quickly,
so the book's
call-- I wanted to call
the book, "The F Word",
first of all.
Because none of us
wanna talk about money.
It's this topic.
It's super stressful.
In fact, like for
a century, like
we've taught everyone
never to talk about money.
It's this totally
impolite thing.
But the problem is,
everyone deals with money.
In fact, we make 6 to 10 money
decisions every single day.
And we will every day that
we're alive on this earth.
I actually go so far as to say
that financial planning should
be, literally should
be a civil right.
Just like sort of
getting access to health
care, because if your
money's in complete disarray,
you can't protect
your family, you
can't take care of
yourself, you can't
lead even a normal average life.
And so, I'm actually
going on this tour.
It's kind of crazy.
I was in Denver this morning,
I was in Nashville yesterday,
Chicago the day before,
Indiana the day before that,
and going back to New York.
Shooting everything
from, tomorrow morning
we're on Good Morning America.
We're supposed to be shooting
Piers Morgan tonight,
all the way to next week
Seattle, San Francisco,
Jacksonville, etc.
Running around the
country, doing this.
Going to high schools colleges,
churches, hospitals, companies.
Literally giving
this money talk so
that everyone gets empowered.
We call it "Financially
Fearless America"
because a really important
rule is, I've probably
talked to well
over 10,000 people,
and I've actually never met a
single person that has said,
I feel great about my money.
It is just this topic of stress,
anxiety, eating cu-- none of us
grew up with enough
money, trust me.
Even if you did, you know
someone who grew up with more.
It's really this topic of
pretty deep stress and strain.
You're not saving enough,
you don't make enough.
Because it literally
is this topic
that you always are comparing.
And the problem with that is, we
know mathematically, about 85%
of the audience
is too embarrassed
and too stressed out to actually
go and jump and make progress.
And about 15% sort of
feels maybe ish confident.
They're like, I think I'm
doing it, I think I'm doing it.
And what we find is
both a really bad,
because you end up not actually
making progress on your money.
Next.
So some really important stats.
Right now, 76% of the country,
and I gave a TED talk on this,
feels out of control when
it comes to their money.
And we describe
exactly what we found.
It is like being in a boat
in the middle of the ocean
and you literally just don't
know which way is land.
That may sound dramatic, but
it's actually pretty accurate.
And the reason, what we
find, is the average person
can spare a lit--
and by the way,
this is obviously not
above the average audience,
and you'll see some stats
about the more money you make,
how things actually can
get more complicated.
But the takeaway here is, you're
in the middle of the ocean.
And let's just say you can spare
a few thousand dollars a month.
Which, let's just
say that that's
what this room can spare.
You then have so
many priorities,
that you're not quite sure
which bucket to fill first.
Do you pay down student debt?
Do you pay down
credit card debt?
Do you contribute to your 401K?
There's a matching program here.
Do you think about 529
plans for your kids?
Do you help your
aging parent, which,
that is a really big new
topic that our generation will
be faced with.
Do you have emergency savings?
Do you contribute
to your mortgage?
I mean, you quickly can see,
that you end up being like,
where does my next dollar go?
Like, how do I prioritize?
And the takeaway is, most
people feel pretty stressed out.
Next.
So right now, 61%
of the country,
so just think about
the whole country,
literally lives
paycheck to paycheck.
Which means that they
are not in the position,
if anything happened, to be
able to go grab some cash
and do something.
Most people have
less than one month
of savings of what
their life costs them.
And what's really interesting,
especially for this room,
is 30% of people who
make over $100,000,
live paycheck to paycheck.
So I say that because
we sort of intuitively
think having more money means
that you have less money
problems.
But we all know
exactly what happens.
You get the slightly
bigger home,
with the nice
marble counter tops.
And you drive the nicer car.
And you go on the
slightly nicer vacations.
So simply having
more doesn't mean
that you have any less problems.
And I make that
point, because when
you think about your
own money, and when
you think about
sort of the we all
do the comparison situation.
Simply because someone
makes more money does not
mean that behind the scenes,
they're in a better situation.
And I can tell you,
we've seen the bus driver
who makes $60,000, who owns
two homes, and has no debt.
And we've seen the
Wall Street guy or gal
who makes $250,000 who has
$20,000 of credit card debt,
doesn't own anything.
And the takeaway there
is, what you make,
and what you do with it are
very, very different things.
Next.
So, I always go
through these excuses
and I say it just because I
have literally-- LearnVest
is massive.
We have hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of users.
Adding anywhere from
about 1000 to 5000 a day.
People write in all the time,
and I read probably at least 50
to 100 emails every day.
And I can't tell you
the number of people
who-- we hear the excuses.
And it's things like, but
I don't have enough money
to care about my money.
And actually, mathematically,
when you have less money,
it is actually more
critical for you
to know where your
next dollar should go.
Which, my whole TED talk was
about how financial planning
should not be a luxury product.
Right now, if you have well
over a million dollars,
there's a slew of places you
can go to get investment advice.
But if you have less,
which 98.6% of the country
has less than a million
dollars, there's
not a lot of great places to go.
In fact, I would argue that
there was not a great place
to go, before LearnVest.
So first, I don't
have enough money.
I'm ashamed.
I don't want to get started.
Last night, I was in Denver,
and a woman who was in her
'60s came up to me and was like,
I cannot tell you what I would
have given for someone to
tell me this when I was
in my '20s, '30s.
Maybe even '40s, because it
could have changed so much.
She was just like here I
am, and I can't do a lot.
So we always say like, the
problem's not going to go away,
you just have to solve it.
And it's about
making that barrier
to solving it pretty low.
We get a lot of, I don't even
know what a financial plan is.
Well, that's what I'm
going to walk through.
That's what the
book walks through.
And I'm gonna share some of
my favorite hacks for you
guys today that are
absolutely worth your time.
And then finally, we
see a lot-- again,
a small portion of
people say I kind of
think I handle on things.
And then we actually
look at their finances
and see that they're
no better off,
but they just sort of
think that they are.
And so the takeaway is,
put those excuses aside.
You already did.
You came to this talk.
But I like to say them out
loud, because they sort of run
through all of our heads.
Next.
So, this is LearnVest.
We literally as I just
said, raised $45 million
with the whole
goal of disrupting
the financial planning space.
Let me talk about what
that means for a second.
Right now, like that whole
offline, go see a planner,
print out your documents,
bring them to them.
It is so anticrated.
When you think about
the incredible things
that a company like Google has
done, or Apple's Genius Bar,
or even Weight Watchers, a
program for your weight loss.
For me, the financial
space is so old school.
Literally, banks are open
from like 9:00 to 5:00.
Actually the bank near me
closes on Saturdays its open
from 11:00 to 2:00.
I'm like wait, what?
It's Saturday.
But it is this last space
that hasn't been completely
disrupted by incredible
technologies.
And so all we did
was pretty simple.
We built an incredible basic
way to filter any household
to make sure that
they know what to do.
And then we connect you
to an expert on our staff.
And then we got
rid of all the BS.
All the friction.
I don't know where
to find someone.
It's way too expensive.
I don't know how to get
them my information.
So the tips that came out,
that are in this book,
are from four years of being
a certified financial planner
myself.
From talking to literally
thousands of customers.
From tremendous
amounts of research.
And I'm going to tell
you guys the one,
because at the end
of the day, I'm
not that different than
you guys, in the sense
that none of us have extra time.
We're all-- you know, you have
your job, you have your family,
you have your kids,
you have your health,
you're juggling so much.
So one of the big
things at LearnVest,
we only share things that
are worth your energy.
Things are going to make a real
impact on your financial life.
Next.
So we developed this thing,
it's called the Action Program.
It's literally a
seven step process.
And it can take any one.
Any household.
One thing you guys
should know is
our users are between 25 and 65.
Our core users are really
in their '30s and '40s,
and they're often households.
You know, if you're
single, it's single.
But if you're
married, it's both.
And we put you
through this filter.
What I'm going to
do today is walk you
all through the filter.
So think about
your own situation.
Think about the tips
that really resonate.
Write down questions.
And again, I'll answer
some broad ones at the end.
And then I can sit up here and
answer one on one questions.
So, the first step is organize.
I cannot tell you guys
the number of people,
really well educated by the way.
So I don't care if you went
to Harvard Business School
and work at Goldman Sachs,
you went to community college,
we don't learn about
this in school.
I had two great educations.
Doesn't matter.
We don't learn about it in
high schools or colleges
across the country.
I was actually just
at the White House
last Thursday with
Congresswomen trying
to figure out how
we can actually
start changing some of
the rules around that.
But the takeaway is,
regardless of your education,
regardless of what you make, we
see disorganization everywhere.
And here's what I mean by that.
First of all, ideally, all
your accounts are online.
I mean, even my husband who
went to Harvard with me,
he still had that
like one account
that doesn't have
anything online.
And I was like,
what are you doing?
We've gotta like,
be able to see that.
You've got to be able to log in.
You can't wait for
paper statements.
Or to have a bank it's
literally in a different state
that you actually
can't go and see.
So one of the things
that we recommend
are, and again, we don't
work with any banks directly.
We don't promote any accounts.
Everything that you do you
should be able to be online.
And I'll give you a quick sense.
So, people come in all
the time and we end up
realizing that they
have like 14 accounts.
When you have a household,
and you have kids,
it quickly can turn
into 20 accounts.
And so we just say,
fewer is better.
Plain and simple.
You know, you're FDI insured
up to a huge amount of money.
And so first, link them to
the LearnVest Money Center.
It's our free tool.
Great, great five
star ratings etc.
If you go to the next slide.
Let me give you some
really specific things.
So first, my accounts, I
actually have personally,
two credit cards.
Now with my husband
I have a third.
I have my Bank of
America account,
because I have ATMs
within three blocks of me
in both places, my
job, and my home.
I have all my money over at
Fidelity, and my 401K is there.
That's it.
That's what we got.
That's what we're working with.
And it's really--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ALEXA VON TOBEL: FDIC?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
split their money
between different accounts
so that none of them
was above the limit.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: If you have,
if you're with a partner,
you have up to $2 million
of FDIC insurance.
And it's across four
types of accounts.
So, I'm not in a position where
I have more than $2 million
of cash, so you're
ultimately protected.
And then if it's in a brokerage
account, it SPIC insurance,
and that's even more.
So the takeaway there is, if
you are in a household that
has less than that,
it makes sense
to be able to put
your money there.
For us, why I just
showed you how
we have our accounts set up,
is because everything then
goes into one email address.
It's basically
Alexasbills@gmail.
I get all of our
statements in one place.
If you looked in my
like Gmail right now,
I have 23,000 unread
emails, because you
know, all of the
alerts that you get.
I get my news alerts
from everything.
And what would find is,
bills, statements, alerts,
things I should probably
be seeing would get lost.
So what we say is, with your
household, link everything
up to a new, fresh,
clean account.
Next with that, then
I run my finances
like I run my social life.
I have my Google
Calendar set up.
And I have some really
specific alerts.
They're outlined in
detail in the book.
But the following: in
January, I contribute
to my IRA, and my 401K.
You guys have matching,
so that's free money.
You should take advantage
of every dollar that.
If you can go above the $17,500
that you can put into a 401K
at work, then you want
to contribute to an IRA.
We recommend that contribute
to an IRA at the beginning
of January because you get
a full extra year of tax
free earnings.
And the takeaway there
is, either sit down
and put in the
$5,500 that you can,
or set it so that it's
going to automatically do it
across the year.
That's an alert on my
calendar in January.
In January, I also go
to all my doctor visits.
I do them all in one month.
And I'll share with you in
more detail a few reasons why.
But your health is
your biggest asset.
And actually, you have
great health insurance,
take advantage of it.
In January I also sit
down with my husband.
And if you have a family,
what are we trying to do?
What are our goals for the year?
What are we trying to save for?
And really sit down
and map it out.
Where do we want
to be in one year?
Three years?
Then break it down into months.
You can really get a sense
of what you should be saving.
These are the beginning
pillars of what
a financial plan looks like.
I also, every three months,
check my credit score.
And every year I check
my annual credit report.
Just again, they're
on annual renews.
They just alert.
I get them on my phone.
It's pretty straightforward.
I can't forget.
But those are the
things that we do.
You then have alerts for when
your credit cards are due.
And I'll go into a
lot more detail what
goes into your credit score, but
the takeaway is, missing a bill
is literally one of the
simplest things that
can hurt your credit
score so badly,
and it's just not worth it.
And particularly the
bills that really mess up
are doctors visits.
Because they're
mom and pop shops.
They tend not to have
great online systems.
Right?
You go to your dermatologist,
they send you a paper bill.
We as young people
in this generation,
we move all the time.
So if you don't do mail
forwarding, you miss a bill,
it's $86.
They turn you over
the credit agencies.
Those are the sort
of things that
happen that really affect
people's credit scores that
are simple.
So what we say is, make sure
you have a uniform system
to track everything
all in one place.
Next, as I said, set
up an email address
where everything comes in.
The average person
doesn't check their bills.
Why we say-- there's
Mint and then there's
LearnVest, and both of
us, you can see everything
in one place.
We have no ads in it.
It's literally just your data.
And one of the things that
I do pretty much every day,
at least every few days, is
login, take a money minute,
and just check what's going on.
The reason I do that is, pretty
much every three months I
find an issue.
And I'll explain
what that means.
Let's say I ate at a
restaurant for $100.
I tip 20%, it was $120.
I will find, if I log
in, sometimes people
change your tips.
It happened.
I'd be like it was--
you're nodding, it happens.
It's crazy.
But I was like, wait,
I didn't tip $40.
And one of the things
is if you don't actually
have everything that's
online, accessible.
Linked through a
place like LearnVest,
where you can see everything
in one place, where
you can log in--
you know, if I go,
I can't tell you what I eat
for dinner seven nights ago.
So if I go look
at a bill, I don't
know if it's exactly right,
but I take the time to do it
and then I use credit cards
where I can dispute things.
So one, I think it's
really important
that everything's online.
I think it's really important
all linked to one place.
And I think it's
really important,
one of the things we learned
is, well over more than half
the country doesn't
even open their bills.
And game here plan number
one is open your bills.
Have them come into
an email address.
And then finally,
I log in once a day
so I can actually
see what's going on.
Next.
Step two is focus.
So this is a really
important step.
And again, we built
this entire system
to put a household
through it, and it's
very thoughtfully
in a certain order.
So first, we've gotta
get you organized,
we gotta know what
your numbers are,
we gotta see exactly
what's happening.
From there, we
have to figure out
what comes in every year or
every month, and what goes out.
And let me explain.
So I can't tell you
the number of people
that are like, I make $100,000.
And I'll be like, you don't.
You make $68,000.
Because you have to think of
your life in after tax dollars.
And the reason why
we say that is, one,
it's really easy to over inflate
what your household income is.
Like, you make $100,000, I make
$200,000, we make $300,000.
But you have to think
about an after tax dollars.
So first, look at
your paychecks.
Quickly figure out,
multiply it by 26 or 27,
based on the number
paychecks you get.
That's the first thing.
What really comes in?
And for freelancers,
for people who
have extra money on the side,
it gets more complicated.
Then, what goes out.
So, plain and simple, you have
your obvious fixed expenses.
Your rent, those sort of things,
that are clear, you know them,
they're very regular.
But on the other stuff,
the restaurant and bars,
the travel, the shopping; that's
the stuff that people never
really have a good grasp on.
And so one of the
things is one, do
you know that there's actually
money at the end of the month?
So, if you're not tracking it,
and again, 61% of the country
is living paycheck to paycheck.
Which basically means they're
spending more than they make.
And so, again, good people with
good incomes, that happens.
So what we look at is what
comes in, what's going out,
and we help you
get a real sense.
And you know, LearnVest has
great trends and analysis.
And at the end, we
find out what is left.
We then go through this is
really good negotiation process
with you where, let's just say,
your household makes $7,000
a month and at the end,
there's only $1,000 left.
We figure out, is there
anything else we can do?
And we have great
tips in the book.
And our planners
literally work and tweak,
and we find a way, how do
we get $1,000 to be $2,000?
Because we can get you towards
your goal so much faster.
So we help you figure
out how to cut costs,
things you can turn
off, really great hacks.
And basically, we
come up with what's
the number at the
end of the month?
Let's just say it's $2,000.
Next.
So one thing is, you
go to your budget.
This is a really important
financial planning principal.
So I'm a CFP, just so you
guys all know what that means.
It basically means you have to
go to school for about a year.
Pass many tests.
You then have to take a
two day, 10 hour exam.
And honestly, it's the hardest
exam I've ever been through.
It's only about a 30% pass rate.
It's not only extremely
broad in the topics
it covers, but extremely deep.
And this is one of
the best principles
that I learned in it.
So, I didn't make
it up, but it's
one of the things that sort
of changed my life, in terms
of thinking about my money.
So let's just say, for
the sake of this example,
that my household makes
$10,000, after taxes.
That's what comes in.
So when you think about
living within your means,
what that really
means, is 50% or less,
should go to essentials.
Essential is what this
actually essential to live.
It's the roof over your
head, it's your groceries,
it's your utility bill, and
it's your transportation
to and from work.
So for you guys, you drive.
So it's not just whatever
your car payment is.
Your auto insurance,
and your gas.
So that's what's essential.
Ideally that's 50% or less.
One of the reasons is, if
you're a two person household,
if someone lost their
job, you would still
be able to maintain
your essentials
without going into debt.
A really important about that
50% is, of the 100, 30% or less
is your rent or mortgage.
So this is the one that
people get wildly wrong.
And I can't tell you the number
of people that will come in,
and their rent or their mortgage
is 60% of what they make.
And we can see in
a 10 second window,
that you're going to
have a pretty jeopardized
financial future, because
of that one decision.
And I say that for
the following reason.
20% is supposed to go
towards the future.
And I'll walk you through why.
But 20% of what you
take home every month
should go to if you have
debt, paying down your debt.
If you don't have
debt, contributing
to your retirement.
If you are already maxing
out your retirement,
your next savings goal,
whatever it may be.
Whether it's saving
for your kids 529 Plan,
helping with some dream,
some small project
you want to work on,
whatever it may be.
And then, 30% is the fun stuff.
That's the lifestyle budget.
That's the like do you
want to go shopping?
Do want to go travel?
Do you want to have an
Equinox membership, etc.
And one of the reasons why
people often will be like,
well my rent's 60%.
And we're like, well
your 20%'s gone.
And the truth is,
you can't really
live on your 30%
being anything--
we say-- people are like,
but I can make that 10%.
Well here's the problem.
Every time your phone
rings, literally every time,
someone's calling you to
ask you to spend money.
They're calling, do you
want to go for margaritas?
Do you wanna go to the gym?
Do you wanna go to the game?
Do you wanna meet for yoga?
Do you wanna get a manicure?
Your parents need
something, doesn't matter.
Every time someone's
calling you ,
they're asking you to do
something that requires money.
And people just don't have the
willpower to always say no.
That's also not a
fun life to live.
And so what we find is,
if you are in a position
where your rent is more than
30% of what you take home,
you often end up
in a big mistake.
You're not saving
enough for the future.
You're in a position where
you wildly have to underspend,
which is pretty difficult
for a lot of people.
And so the takeaway
there is, my mentor,
she's one of the early
founders of Goldman Sachs.
And she's on the board of
Goldman Sachs, said to me
early when we were building
LearnVest together, she goes,
Alexa, the number
one thing you can
do to always keep your
finances in shape,
is always spend
beneath your needs
in your living environment.
And so if it's rent,
that's pretty clear.
But for your mortgage, is
what we call PITY, principal
and interest, taxes
and insurance,
because those are the
four things that you
must have in order to be
able to afford that home.
So right now, if
you're way over 30%,
we don't recommend you
go sell your house.
It's just, you need to be aware
that you're actually at risk.
So next.
Really quickly,
on credit scores,
this is one of the ones
guys, that I can't tell you,
I had like almost a full
hour of questions last night
about this.
And it's pretty regular.
Here's the takeaway, your
credit score really matters.
As extremely smart, talented
people in this room,
it is the only
grade that matters
after you leave the
education system.
And here's why it matters.
So over my life, in
the next 60 years,
I'm gonna buy probably
four or five homes.
I'm probably also going
to like, get a nice car,
start another business,
whatever it may be.
Every time I go
to borrow, they're
going to look at one number.
They're going to be like,
what's your credit score?
They'll look at your income too,
but that's basically the grade.
From there, it's the difference
of 4% interest or 3% interest,
based on what it looks like.
Over 40 or 50 years, that
could be more than $100,000,
$200,000, of saved
earnings in interest,
because my credit score is good.
It's that simple.
And again, this is literally
why I was in Washington.
I was making it so that credit
scores, and giving college kids
credit cards,
should be outlawed.
The average college senior
gets their credit score
on like, Freshman welcome day,
with a free piece of pizza.
And they graduate with
$4,000 in credit card debt.
And they're already
in a position
where they also have
$20,000 in student debt
and they make less than that
in their first few years out
of school.
So as a result, it's
really hard for them
to change that situation.
So, credit score really matters.
It ranges from 300 to 850.
Everyone in this room, you
want it to be about 700.
Ideally, it's above 760.
That's considered excellent.
That makes a big difference.
And here are the three things.
Only look at the top three,
because the ones at the bottom
aren't even worth your time.
Number one, payment history.
Never miss a bill.
Missing a bill knocks it about
60 points, even up to 100.
And it takes literally a year,
two years, three years to fix.
Something as simple as
an $86 dermatology bill.
Number two, is your
credit utilization rate.
So what's important
about this, and it
sounds like a complicated
concept, it's not.
Let's just pretend I
had one credit card,
and it was $10,000,
that was my limit.
So I have one credit card,
let's just say $10,000 limit.
If you're carrying no debt, you
don't have to care about this.
If you're carrying zero
credit card debt at all times,
you always pay
your bills in full,
you're at 0% for that
credit utilization.
You're in good shape.
If you are carrying
debt, and let's say
that I'm carrying $5,000
of debt on that one credit
card, that $10,000 limit, I'm
utilizing my limit at 50%.
If it's above 50%,
red flags go off.
So you first, want to get your
credit below 30% utilization.
Which means, across
all your credit cards,
you have to know what
your total limit is.
But Additionally, the
takeaway, the big thing
here is, just pay down your
debt as quickly as you can.
That's the best way to improve
this, and it is a huge portion.
And then finally, your
length of history.
So, the take away
here is, you want
to go to annual credit report
once a year, as I told you
in the beginning.
You want to print out
that credit report.
And you wanna look
at all the things
that are associated with
your social security number.
I promise you, you
will find mistakes.
Most people do.
And the takeaway is,
you want to know,
not only what's
associated with you,
so that you can dispute
anything that's not yours.
But also, you may
find, you know,
that silly Bloomingdale's
credit card that you
opened to save 15%,
blah, blah, blah.
And the takeaway there
is, what you want to do
is, never close your
oldest credit card.
And the reason being is, that's
your longest line of history.
So that's what goes
into your credit score.
It really matters.
And the takeaway is,
don't miss bills,
pay your debt down to zero, and
don't close your oldest credit
card.
One important thing is
if you're sitting here
and you have seven credit cards,
don't go out and close all
them.
You really can only
close one credit per year
because it affects
that utilization.
What it does is,
it starts quickly
lowering your ability
for limit very quickly.
And it can make or
your credit score dip.
So don't do anything
major with your credit.
Also, if you're going out and
borrowing in the next year,
or going back to grad school,
or anything like that, because
it will dip a little bit.
So.
I love the site called
CreditKarma.com.
I know the founders.
They're good people.
They have the same mission
that LearnVest does.
To empower people.
And you can check your
credit score there for free.
Next.
After all of that's
done, you're organized,
you know your numbers,
you know where you stand,
you know your net worth,
then we go into Planning.
So go back to, remember
I said my household,
let's just say at
the end of it, I
have $2,000 of free
money every month.
So we then make
that money, it has
to go essentially
to three things.
This is three priorities
before anything else.
First, paying down your debt.
Second, is dealing
with your retirement
and making sure that
you're on track.
And we run this really
simple rule for you.
We can take anyone in this
room, find out how old you are,
find out what lifestyle you
would like in retirement,
and look at your account and we
can tell you if you're on track
or not.
And then finally, an
emergency savings account.
So when you think about
financial planning,
these are three
essential pillars
that are critical to starting.
And I can't tell you the
number of really smart people
that start being like, I wanna
invest and I wanna buy a home.
And we're like, you
can't do that until you
make sure you've covered
these three things.
So let's run through
them really fast.
And guys I'm gonna go a
little faster because there's
a ton of good content in
here I wanna get through.
So really quickly,
good debt, bad debt.
All debt is not created equal.
Bad debt is credit card
debt, and it's car loans.
The second you drive a car off
the lot, depreciating asset.
So, any debt that has
a depreciating asset,
is considered bad debt, and
it hurts your credit score,
and you want to get rid of it.
Good debt is things like
student debt and your mortgage.
The asset in a house,
hopefully it goes up in value
and it's not considered
as negatively
against your credit score.
And then student debt, and guys,
you know, the entire nation
is under a trillion
dollars of student debt.
So I can't tell you the number
of people who have come in.
My brothers are doctors.
One's a surgeon.
Hundreds of thousands of
dollars of student debt.
The good thing there is, the
government has set up a system,
because our brain is the asset,
and they're investing in us,
so that we can actually
earn greater for the future.
The one takeaway there
is, I can't tell you
the number of people
that come and say,
I'm going to go to x school.
I'm gonna pay $100,000 to get a
master's degree, and I'm like,
is it going to increase your
salary enough to pay it down?
So don't just collect
degrees for the sake of it.
If it can't increase your
salary, it's pretty tough.
Next.
So, retirement.
This is a really simple graph.
I brilliantly came up with
it, it's so complicated.
It's so simple.
You're 25 years old.
I wanna retire at 65.
I live to 95.
So I work for 40 years
to fund 70 years.
Plain and simple.
I only really work
for half the time
that I will be funding myself.
So if you are not
putting away at least 20%
towards the future, you're
not going to be on track.
It's that simple.
And I was literally
with the head
of the treasury for
all Colorado yesterday.
And we were talking about
the fact that, literally
quick history tip here.
In the '70s, pretty much all
of our parents, a lot of them,
had pensions and
Social Security.
They literally, we, as a country
would fund your retirement.
The problem is, great
science is happening.
We're living much longer.
And companies started flailing
because growing populations,
they weren't able to keep up.
So what happened is, we went
from a very paternalistic
government, where we were trying
to fund people in retirement,
and we shifted it to you and us
all funding our own retirement,
via the 401K.
The big problem was, there
was no education about that.
So they gave us
the responsibility,
but didn't make us really
understand the big impact.
And the result is, most people
are off track for retirement.
And it's really tough,
because a lot of our parents
are not going to be on track.
And so it means that we
will be funding our parents.
And I'm telling you guys, I see
this from even affluent people.
Where there just like, my mom's
living til she's 98 years old.
And it's $100,00 to have care.
It's very expensive.
And as a result, our money
could be filtering out.
Which means, we're worse off,
and our children are worse off.
And it's this huge
domino effect.
So the takeaway here
is, walk away from here,
increase your 401K.
If your 401K maxed
out, which is awesome,
go contribute to an IRA.
Next.
Quick graph.
When I was Harvard undergrad,
I was like such a math dork,
that I like went to a money
presentation that I found.
And here's the
really simple things.
Compounding interest.
It's not magic it's math.
And Jessica starts
when she's 20.
She puts away the same
dollar amount as Kate.
Literally at retirement,
simply putting the same dollars
but with a 20 year
difference, what happens
is, Jessica has over a quarter
of a million dollars more.
So if you think about
the biggest hacks
that you can possibly
come up with,
right now, before you have
a lot of responsibilities,
put away as much money as
possible into retirement.
That's the takeaway.
And one thing you
guys should know,
is we see a lot of
people in their late '30s
early '40s with a few
kids, with mortgages,
thinking about
their kids college.
And they never contributed
to their retirement.
And it's really hard once you're
in that position, where you're
running a full household,
to find extra money.
So the takeaway is, you
want to contribute ideally
before you have kids.
And again, wish this was a
class, before you have kids.
Because once you do have a
family, it gets much harder.
And this is a great
earning audience,
so you will always
be able to be maybe
better off the average American.
But it's still pretty hard.
And so, I'm lazy.
Start early.
It does the work for you.
Which is great.
Step four, is Build.
So then, after we
get through that.
We've made sure those
three things are on track
and have a game plan.
In step four, this
is when you should
start to think about
the other things.
Am I having children?
Do I like my home?
Do we want to upgrade our home?
Are we thinking about
starting a small business?
a vacation to Tahiti?
I love the customers that walk
in the door and their like,
I truly wanna go on a trip.
And we're like, let's
first make sure that we
can cover you and protect you.
So, then we start to
build towards the future.
We have these really
great tracking devices.
It's all through
the money center,
that you can set up goals.
We show you how many months
you're going to be there,
and we do it all
automatically for you.
Step five is Protect.
And I'm going to take an extra
few minutes on this one guys,
because this is one of
the most important things
that you will learn that
I will say here today.
So, my same mentor who was
a professor at Columbia
basically was like,
Alexa, what if I
could promise that you
will never go bankrupt.
I'm like, that'd be pretty cool.
Put me in coach.
What do I have to do?
And the takeaway was,
be properly insured.
LearnVest doesn't
sell insurance.
In fact, I don't like people,
typically, who sell insurance.
Because they get big
chunks of commission.
And they typically tell you
probably more than you need.
But what is important about
this is, insurance is actually,
in the financial
planning exam, it's
step one of a financial plan.
We made it step
five, because people
tend to be pretty daunted by it.
And it's not a sexy topic.
It is not fun.
I actually joke that I
drank a whole bottle of wine
while I was writing the
chapter on Protect Yourself.
But it is so critical, you guys.
And let me give you a
few important examples.
So first, 62% of the country
that went bankrupt this year,
went bankrupt not because
they didn't have insurance,
because they were
improperly insured.
Meaning, they didn't know
what they're riders said.
They didn't know Hurricane
Sandy-- my husband's family had
a house in this place
called Breezy Point.
Literally most people lost
almost everything they had.
And it was because
they didn't know
that they didn't
have flood insurance.
And when it flooded, sorry.
That's not covered.
And it's literally
critical for you to know,
what's not covered,
what is covered.
Am I in a place where, I
was in Denver yesterday
with tornadoes.
Do you have tornado coverage?
You need it.
If you're in California,
earthquake coverage.
And the takeaway
here is, I'm going
to walk through all the
types but, insurance.
One, it's not that
expensive, often.
But it is critical
that you layer it
into your financial plan.
And one thing for me, you
know, I built LearnVest,
not because I want
people to be rich,
but I want people to be
able to enrich their life.
And for me, what's invaluable,
is financial security.
So that anything in
the world can happen,
and I don't have to
worry about the money.
You can lose your job tomorrow,
and you have a game plan
to figure that out.
Someone in your family can
get sick, and you're OK.
And you guys are going
to be able to focus
on the person who's
sick, not all the money
implications of it.
And when I promise you,
like life will happen.
I share in the first
chapter of the book,
one of the reasons
I'm really passionate
about personal finance
is, when I was 14,
my dad unexpectedly passed away.
My mom had three kids.
And she didn't even know
where our money was.
So there, she was dealing
with a major life event,
scrambling to figure out
what to do with our finances.
And I think what's really
important is, in those moments,
that's why you have
a financial plan.
So you can look at
whoever's really suffering
and say, we're fine, we're
going to figure it out.
So the takeaway on insurance,
if you go through quickly.
Next slide.
So you can't read it, but I can.
You need homeowners,
and you need renters.
I have an employee who actually
literally just started, got
renters insurance, because
she's working at LearnVest,
and everyone who
works at LearnVest
has a full financial plan.
Her apartment was on
top of a pizza place
and the oven caught on fire,
and burned her entire apartment
down.
She lost 90% of what she owns.
And she came to me.
She had like two weeks
out of the office
to deal with the crisis.
She came to me was like, because
of you, I get all new stuff.
All new.
And renters insurance
is $20 month.
And I mean, these
stories happen,
and they happen all the time.
And I get to hear about them,
because all the emails come in.
But it's critical.
So homeowners insurance, and
you need renters insurance.
Disability, I'm pretty
positive that Google offers it.
Opt in today.
You are 10 times more
likely to be disabled then
you are to die.
And the takeaway there is,
if something bad happens,
you want to make
sure that you're
getting not just Any
occupation, but Own occupation.
That's the key.
That replaces whatever
salary you currently have.
If you have Any, so
let's say you work here,
and let's say you make $100,000.
And you have Any disability
insurance called Any.
What it means is, if you can
go work at McDonald's, you
don't get $1.
Because you get a $30,000
job at McDonald's.
So it's really important
that you know the difference.
Term, you need it.
You need, if you're
married, if you have kids,
you need life insurance.
And again, our
experts from LearnVest
will tell you the
exact dollar amount.
They will tell you exactly
what you really can afford,
and what you should
be protecting.
If you have a lot
of assets, if you're
someone who has a
really nice home, who
has money coming
from their family.
You want maybe
umbrella insurance.
You want to further
protect your assets.
Long term care, this is
a pretty fascinating one.
And because we are all living
longer, in your '30s and '40s,
you can buy long term
care pretty inexpensively.
And it all depends on
what your medical history
is, and things like that.
But like, my
grandmother, who I saw
last Sunday is 95 years old,
and she's like, kicking.
She is like, icy as hell.
And I'm like, oh my
god, she's going live
for like, 10 more years maybe.
And the home she lives in
is like really expensive.
It's like $90,000 a year.
And luckily, she was
able to afford that.
But I wouldn't be able to pay
for that if that happened.
And so one of the
things that's important
is, this is an insurance that
may make sense in your '30s
and '40s to potentially get.
And then we also walk
through these documents.
And I'll give you estate
planning documents,
as boring as they are.
You can go to
LegalZoom, you actually
get a discount through
LearnVest at LegalZoom.
Fill them out.
Takes a few minutes.
And I'll give you an example.
If you have a child, and you
don't have a Guardian letter,
those are the sort of things
that we call red flags.
And we would help you do first.
Because money doesn't matter.
But if, God forbid,
something happens to you
and you don't know
who's actually
become the legal
guardian of your child,
for me that's step one.
And so that's the sort
of stuff that our program
takes into account.
And what we do is we put
you through the filter,
and we figure out
all the things that
are critical that you must do.
And then we start talking about
the things you want to do.
Next.
And then finally,
step six is Maximize.
And so, really smart people,
and I mean really smart people,
come in the door of LearnVest
every day, and they're like,
I want to invest.
And we're like, yeah,
we'd love you to invest.
But let's first
make sure that you
have those pillars in
place, and that you're
protected from everything.
And if at the end of that,
you still have extra money,
then here's what we ask you.
So we'll look at
your 401Ks, we'll
make sure that you have the
appropriate asset allocation,
we'll make sure that
they're invested
in things that are inexpensive.
I'm going to assume that
you have a great 401K here.
But outside of that.
Let's say I have an
extra pocket of money
after getting through
all of those steps,
but my husband and I
are going to buy a house
in New York in the next
two or three years.
Money shouldn't be invested.
It should have zero
equity exposure.
And so we put you
through a few things.
One is the rule of five.
Do you need the money
in the next five years?
If it's money to go on a trip,
to go start a small business.
Just literally,
you want to have it
there because you're
having a baby in a year.
We're like, no, no,
you can't invest it.
So literally, rule of five.
If you need it in
five years, it should
have zero equity exposure.
The other thing is quick--
AUDIENCE: What's
equity exposure?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So literally
it's any set of stocks.
It's ETFs that have
like an S&P 500,
it's anything where
the underlying
asset is portions of companies.
What we would
recommend, potentially
again, depending on who you
are and what your goals are,
is things like CD
ladders or bonds.
And long story short, another
important tip that maybe you'll
appreciate is, for
your 401K or your IRA,
which are both just investment
accounts for retirement,
most people can't maximize.
It's $23,000 a year
you can put away.
You should be doing
that, before you
should be doing anything else.
And what we look at is,
it's called the rule of 120.
You take 120 and
you minus your age.
So let's say I'm 30.
120 minus 30.
90% should have equity
exposure, because that's
where all the risk is.
And over the last century, the
average stock market return,
the average over
a century is 10%.
So that's great.
And in fact, you
need to be investing
to outlive that inflation,
which is 3% a year.
The takeaway here,
a lot of people
just quickly jump to conclusions
mat, and they're like,
I should be investing.
And the takeaway is, it's
really about these principles
to make sure that you're doing
it in the right thematic order.
And then step
seven is literally,
anytime your life
changes, we gotta
rerun every scenario for you.
And one thing I
will tell you guys
is, if you're doing
anything major,
if you're buying a home,
if you're having a child,
if you're changing majorly
jobs, moving across coasts.
If you're in a position where
someone in your family is sick.
You're going to
major life event,
take the time to
talk to an expert.
It is critical.
You don't know all the
things you don't know.
And it's not all Google-able.
You can't go and find them.
And the real big key here
is, before LearnVest existed,
it was thousands of dollars to
be able to talk to an expert.
But one thing that
we really say is,
these big things that
you're going through, I just
talked about
insurance, the riders
are like multiple, multiple
pages of fine print.
You're no lawyer.
Like you're not an
insurance expert.
It's worthwhile to make sure
that God forbid, Hurricane
Sandy or an earthquake
happens, you're protected.
And you guys can
absolutely all afford
to be able to talk to an expert.
And it's worthwhile.
And I'll just say, as part of
just the LearnVest program,
we actually worked with a bunch
of behavioral experts from MIT,
and some really serious
behavior scientists.
And figured out that a lot
of people learn this stuff,
and then it's overwhelming,
so they don't actually do it.
So one of the things that
we're doing, it's January.
90% of the country's financial
resolutions is do it.
And when I wrote the book,
if you go to the next slide.
So when I wrote the book, one
of the things that we did was,
we wanted to make not only
financial planning affordable,
but we wanted people
to actually do it.
So just 10 seconds on
how our company works,
because you guys obviously
are so attached to the web.
So it's literally
like a gym membership.
You pay an up front fee, you
get connected to an expert,
and then it's $19 a month,
and you can shut it off
at any time.
If you go to the next slide.
Here's what the process is.
You fill out an online profile,
and this asks you everything.
Where are you today?
Where do you want to go?
What would you like
to have happen?
What does financial
security mean for you?
What are the risks that
keep you up at night?
And we actually go
and build everything.
Next.
You get your own dedicated
financial planner
through LearnVest.
These are people on our staff.
They're CFPs, which
I just told, in order
to even be a CFP
you by nature have
to have about four
years of experience.
Most of ours have 10.
But you get the same
dedicated expert,
and they're on demand for you.
If you go to the next slide.
So this is literally what a
financial plan looks like.
We built our own software
because the stuff
that was out there
was pretty bad.
What it does is
literally, and you
can't see it necessarily
perfectly is, we literally
build you a budget.
Show you where every
single dollar should go.
We even then build a calendar.
And it shows you, so
go back to let's say
you have $2,000 at
the end of the month
that you can use
toward your goals.
We break it down month by
month, where it should go
and what it should look like.
And I think the
takeaway here is,
this is what a financial
plan looks like.
It is dollar per dollar.
And what I love about
financial planning
is, guys I come from
a family of doctors.
You know, when it
comes to cancer like,
it's really stressful because
we don't have the answer.
Like, we're working in labs
trying to figure it out.
Financial planning,
and why I believe
with all my heart
and soul, literally
should be accessible to
everyone in the country is,
it's just math.
It is not-- at the
end of the day, what's
complicated is the rules
and all the legislation.
But if you know what
someone's dollar amount is,
you can put it through a
system and you can tell them
exactly what they need to do.
And so anyways, we
build you a calendar.
And then the final thing is, we
literally give you unlimited,
if you go to the next
slide, we give you
unlimited phone
and email support.
Your expert's on demand for you.
Put them on your speed dial.
And you always get
the same person.
And so, this is
in a nutshell what
I've spent the last four
years of my life building.
If you go to the next slide.
Google got you guys
books, which is awesome.
In the book, everyone
gets a $50 credit
if you want to work
with your own expert.
And if anyone wants
to get a plan,
we just as a thank you
for having us here,
we'll give you an
extra month of service.
But I'm going to
stand up here, and I'm
going to answer any questions.
And the one thing I will
say that's so important
is, everyone can make progress.
I would gamble to say
that everyone in this room
is in a pretty good
situation, where you actually
have extra money at
the end of the month
that you can put towards goals.
So then it's a matter of making
sure that actually happens.
But anyways.
Most people are pretty stressed.
Lots of people have
questions, so I'm
going to stay as late
as I possibly can,
before I go to the other Google.
What's your question?
AUDIENCE: OK.
My question is something you
said about credit reports.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Credit rating.
AUDIENCE: And, I
want to make sure I
understood what you said, so--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yep.
AUDIENCE: You said,
credit utilization
is based on a balance
held over a period.
So it wouldn't be the amount a
person used and then paid off.
That doesn't count towards
credit utilization?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: You're
absolutely correct.
So let's just say, I actually
have an American Express credit
card.
Also you guys should call and
actually increase your credit
limits if you are able,
if you have good credit.
So I have an American Express
card with a $50,000 limit.
If I go buy a car on
it, which by the way
would give me great points.
My whole life is 1% on
sale, which is awesome.
And I pay it off in full
every month, no issue.
But American Express doesn't
let you carry a balance anyways.
But if you have three credit
cards, total limit of $10,000,
and you're carrying $10,000
of debt month over month,
that's when you
are in big trouble.
And the key there is, just pay
your credit card off in full.
And for those--
AUDIENCE: Every credit
report I actually got,
ever, told me that
my revolving balance
is negative [INAUDIBLE] let's
say $10,000 credit limit.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yep.
AUDIENCE: My revolving
balance is like, $3,000,
but it's paid off every
month, the credit report still
said that's negative
on my credit report.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Because
you're spending-- but
are you carrying
any of the debt?
AUDIENCE: No.
ALEXA VON TOBEL:
Month over month?
AUDIENCE: Nothing's
carried forward.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: I think you may
have a misunderstanding there.
Because if you pay it
off in full every month,
you're good to go.
So, that's the key.
And again, you can send
us your credit report,
and we'll actually walk you
through it if you want us to.
Step by step.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
like, you're
using too much of your credit.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Ask for more.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
What I would do is, if you
have a good credit score,
first I'd call.
One of the reasons why we tell
you to increase your credit
limit, is it boosts your
credit score a little bit.
But also, if God forbid, like
shit totally hits the fan,
you are in a position
where you can go out
and access, God forbid something
really catastrophic happens.
We would never want you to
use credit, but is there.
And so it's one of the
things, and for example,
also when you get really
sophisticated with your money,
I have a $50,000 credit limit.
I could by a car, and
get points for it.
Which actually means
it's like 1% to 2% off.
That's the sort of
stuff that like really
is sort of maximizing
your finances.
Go ahead.
And-- Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: If everybody
can come to the microphone.
It's just better
for the recording.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Oh, perfect.
Sorry.
Everyone come to the microphone.
And guys, I love
these questions.
I get them nonstop.
And there's really, like
there's no such thing
as a dumb question.
AUDIENCE: My question,
you mentioned Mint.com,
which I've been using,
and it's been helpful.
But there are some bugs with it.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like certain
accounts don't work at all.
And the biggest one for me
is our Google stock account
doesn't work with it.
So I'm just wondering if you
know if your software does,
and what the differences between
your software and Mint are?
ALEXA VON TOBEL:
So great question.
And I love you for asking that.
So first, our biggest--
AUDIENCE: Other reasons as well.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
The first biggest
difference, and I
think Mint is a great tool
that you can see everything
in one place.
We don't recommend anything.
In fact, what I don't
like what Mint does,
is they do make all these
recommendations of products.
You opening extra
credit cards, not
good for your
finances at it's core.
Good for Mint, they'll get $150.
But the other thing is, so
we run no ads through it.
But the real key is,
if you're working
with one of our
experts, they can,
once you upgrade, and
work with a planner, boom.
They can see your entire
account right there.
They can set goals for you.
They can set budgets for you.
You don't have to
communicate anything.
You don't have to take the
time and energy to say,
here's all my paperwork.
Here's what's going on.
So the biggest real difference
is, the tool is free for us,
and it's just part of the app.
It's working with a
planner that actually
makes you change your finances.
So, that's the
biggest difference.
And for the Google stock, I
do not know the exact answer.
We'll get back to you as
soon as I possibly can.
Go ahead.
I wish I had Google
stock, that'd be awesome.
AUDIENCE: So beyond insurance
and financial investments,
retirement savings,
is there anything
you think most people don't
spend or consume enough?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: I mean I
really can tell you this.
I don't care what
your household looks
like, if you walk
in the door for us,
we find big blind spots.
Things that you
were like, whew, you
don't have like the right
level of auto insurance.
That's not good.
You drive like,
seven times a day.
So one of the things that
we find out, and again,
like step one.
Get organized.
Have less.
Follow it.
Track it.
I mean, you guys saw all
the crazy Target stuff.
Neiman Marcus got broken into
today, their credit cards.
Track it.
Because it behooves you-- sorry.
It behooves you in
every single way.
So we get you organized.
Then we make sure
that you actually
know what you can spare.
And a lot of people
don't spare as much
as-- if you're making $10,000
a month, your household,
we're like, save $3,000.
Come on.
Like, let's do it.
And then we can start
working towards your goals.
And I think, to
answer your question,
those goals include
things like, you
need to be able to pay
premiums on insurance.
Because that's actually step one
of protecting your household.
So most people do not
have the right insurance.
They don have the right
legal documents in place.
And it sounds
really complicated,
but what's great
about our experts,
they just tell you to do.
They're like, shh.
Here's what you need.
We don't sell anything.
So we're totally
aligned with you.
And then, go talk to these
three providers and go.
Now you're armed in
a position to get it.
So that's the
biggest thing, is I
think most people
aren't saving enough,
and then they just don't know
what their blind spots are,
necessarily.
And they're often not paying
what they need to on insurance.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned not closing
you're oldest credit card.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is that per provider?
I'm in the position where
I just actually changed
Bank of America cards to
a to a rewards version.
If I close the old one and
start using the old one instead,
is that going to
create a discontinuity?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Potentially.
So one of the things
that you should know
is, I had like a card when I was
16, 17, that my mom had opened.
And I had like a
junior card on hers.
First that wasn't
building my credit,
but that was my oldest
line of history.
I then have another
line of credit--
I had my own credit card that
I opened when I was like 21.
So oldest credit card.
I then said hey, I'd
like to change that card
to better card that would
suit my needs today.
And they were like,
if you close it,
that ends that line of credit.
And so the takeaway
there is, sometimes
it does make sense to
keep a credit card that's
not like your
favorite, because it
is you're oldest line of
credit, and to get another card.
And so like I'll give you a
sense of some of the cards
that we like.
So one in general, free American
Express cards are great.
You get points,
and they actually
make you pay them off
in full every month.
So I like that.
You're not able to
carry debt there.
Chase has a great
freedom rewards card
for people who like, spend
a lot on groceries and gas.
So when you're outside
of New York City,
and you're driving a ton.
Great.
5% back.
So I would say go
open another card
and use it and
just keep it open.
Because there's not any risk.
If you have just a few credit
cards and you monitor them.
What I don't like are like,
they Ann Taylor cards, the Gap
cards.
All that BS, which actually,
it's a funny story.
Over the holidays, I was
buying a $17 shirt at the Gap,
like a work out t-shirt.
And they were like, would you
like to open a line of credit?
You'll save $4 today.
And I almost punched
the poor woman.
I was like, you're talking
to the wrong girl right now.
[LAUGHTER]
ALEXA VON TOBEL:
But the takeaway
there is, those are the cards
that don't even have on-- you
can't log into some of them.
The national average on a
credit card is 17% negative APR.
On those cards,
it's often like 30%.
So that compounds
daily, by the way.
The best savings account in
the country is 1% right now.
So, they're horrible.
So the takeaway, I would say,
leave your oldest one open,
and then go get another credit
card that you really like.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank You.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
create a statement
if your balance is not zero.
So there's no statement
that shows that you paid.
[INAUDIBLE].
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
I mean.
It's nuts.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I
have two questions.
The first is, what about opening
checking and savings accounts?
Do those affect
your credit score?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Not at all.
A checking account, a
debit card is not credit.
So that's one thing that's
really important guys.
Debit, credit, like
black and white.
And then opening things
like savings accounts,
that's totally fine.
One of things that
I don't like is
when you have a mutual fund
at this old brick and mortar
store that you like
aren't tracking,
and don't even know if like--
one of the reasons why we like
people to really
consolidate is, we
need to look at-- so I'm
just going to make this up.
Let's say I have
a million dollars,
across like my cash
and my investments.
We have to look at your
portfolio as a whole.
Is everything properly allocated
based on what your goals are?
And when you have a
little bit of money
there, a little
bit of money there,
a little bit of money here,
you can't track it all.
It's much harder to look
at it as the full picture.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And so you recommended calling
our credit card companies
and asking them to increase
your line of credit.
So last time I did
that on my credit card,
they asked me for a reason.
What is the reason that you
recommended getting that.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
So, there's scripts
like this in the book,
if you have credit card debt,
exactly how you can potentially
negotiate it down.
You may not always win.
But you can say, I've just
been a really healthy customer.
As you can see, I
pay my debt in full,
and I ultimately want to be
able to use this card more.
That's what they want to hear.
That's how they make money.
So you're like, I just want to
be able to use this card more.
It's my favorite credit card.
Boom, you're done.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEXA VON TOBEL:
They're like, please,
thank you for spending
on my credit card.
AUDIENCE: Are your
financial planners
able to work with you if you
have accounts internationally,
in addition to US?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So,
it's pretty fun for us
how many people are
like can you help us.
So, one of the
things, it depends
exactly what the situation is.
And I can spend a lot more
time to like ask you in detail,
but the takeaway is, if you have
accounts in other countries,
we can help you
think that through.
But if you were like
a Canadian citizen,
and everything is there, and you
happen to just be living here,
we're not going to be the best.
Because you're
going to be dealing
with like 401Ks in Canada that
are actually very different.
They're called like
RBSs, or something.
But the takeaway is, if
you have a few accounts
abroad, we can help
you think it through.
But if you are living full
time in the United States,
and like going to stay
here for a long time.
And I want to go abroad as
quickly as we possibly can,
I'm just dealing with customers
coming in every minute right
now in the US.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I was wondering can you
make mortgage payments
on like credit cards
and get points back?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: That's
a really great question.
So a few things.
It depends.
The most likely answer
is absolutely not.
But one thing that
is really helpful
is, if you want to
be in a position
where you are just
like hacking your life,
you can make your mortgage
payments twice a month,
instead of once a month.
Where you make an extra payment
throughout the entire year.
So instead of 12 payments
you can make 13 payments.
Is what it adds up to.
And so that's one of the
best things we help you do.
Because also that
interest compounds daily.
So what it not only does is
force you just to budget better
and actually make an extra
payment, but over time,
we like, and it's in the book.
We like, run a scenario for
you of like how much you
can save on interest
simply just by doing that.
So that would be a smarter tip.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: So, one
thing that I think
that when I've looked
at what CFPs can provide
for me, or for
people in general,
it's like a lot of
when you've got money
that you need to put in
different pots, that's
one thing.
But like, if you have like
a question about should I
become a landlord?
That's a harder
question to answer,
and I'm wondering how do you
deal with something like that?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So actually, I
mean that's like a pretty not--
that's a pretty standard
question that we get.
For a few reasons.
Actually, what's amazing
about the financial system
in the United States is,
once you get really organized
and start getting
pretty healthy,
there's so much awesome
stuff you can do.
So then we're like,
second properties,
where you can become a landlord,
and all the tax benefits.
And there's like tax shelters
that are really complex,
but if you are in a position
where you can potentially
become a landlord,
we could show you
exactly what the
benefits would be.
So that's a pretty standard
question, actually.
We have a lot of customers
who are landlords, or who
have rental properties, that
have been beneficial tax
benefits.
And then, if you
have kids, there's
so much cool stuff
that you can do.
I'll give you a
10 second example.
Your parents can actually tax
free, pay for their educations.
Move money to your
children's accounts.
You can overfund
your first 529 plan
so that your second
kids are going
to be better taken care of.
I mean, there's so much stuff
once you're in a position
where you have extra money.
So in fact, I should
have said, you know,
our average customer's household
individual incomes are actually
above $75,000 to $100,000,
and household incomes
are in the $200,000
to $300,000 range.
Those customers come in, and
we can do so much for them.
But we also sign
up 23-year-olds who
are like, I'm just
getting started.
And we're like,
yes, get started.
Because then you'll
be in position
to be able to have more
money for the future.
So when you have
healthier finances,
there's so much more you can do.
And yes, we answer
that question a lot.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
One is the, one of the
frustrating things about,
about online-- about
the packages that
pull your online accounts
is that there's always
this account where you can't
really pull the information.
So do you have some
kind of system?
I just put it into a
spreadsheet and upload it, or?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
Even better.
We just let you add
a manual account
so you can add
any-- first of all,
you can link to LearnVest
literally everything.
Debt, student debt, mortgages,
credit cards, small businesses.
You could actually link
your entire small business
into LearnVest and have
your own small business
if you're a small
business owner.
You can add assets
like jewelry, cars,
literally like solid assets.
You can add things
like annuities.
You can pull those through.
And then, if anything
doesn't link,
so some people
have credit unions.
And they're like these
tiny little very like--
and one of the things is,
we'll look at your credit union
and be like, is it
worth you keeping it?
Are the benefits so strong?
And if you can't link it,
you can add a manual account.
And your planner just
helps you do that.
But also, the planner helps
you evaluate whether or not
you should keep those accounts.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question
has to do with privacy.
I mean, if I join, I'm going to
like, everything is open to you
guys.
How do you deal with that?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So, 10
seconds on that answer.
So number one, it's
actually just a mirror in.
I think you guys as
like technologists
will appreciate this.
You can't move a dollar.
It is a mirror into what's
happening with your finances.
So first, there's
no account numbers,
it's just a window into what's
happening with the money.
So you can't accidentally
have it hacked and move money,
you're not at risk.
There's no account numbers
or anything like that.
Second, were a registered
investment adviser.
We report to the SEC.
So, we go through
compliance both technical,
literally running all of
our technical compliance,
but also internal compliance,
every literal month.
But the takeaway here is,
deeply safe and secure.
Also just one of our
very recent investments
was places like American
Express Ventures invested,
because American
Express eventually
is going start offering
LearnVest with their credit
cards.
As a bene-- not a benefit
that they pay for,
but as a way to help improve
their customer's well being.
So we have to go through
all their technical scrutiny
as well.
So, yes, yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
I recently reread "The
Millionaires Next Door".
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yep
AUDIENCE: And one of the
things that they mentioned--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: I loved those.
AUDIENCE: Is that people who are
wealthier or good accumulators
of wealth actually
spend about eight hours
a month managing their money.
Do you have like
a recommendation
for how much time we
should be spending a month,
and also, do you see
that prolong over time,
or once you have like,
hopefully, you know,
I would love to get the point
where everything is set up.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like do you
see that time decreasing?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
So a few things.
What I just described
for you, And again,
like I could have sat here for
five more hours, to be honest,
was a system.
The program that we built is a
system, that literally hacks.
You saw, as I was
describing it, like we
make you do the 50,
20,30, because that 20%
should be going into
your retirement,
and we should get
that automated.
So what we create
is a foundation
that runs a system
that automates it,
so that it runs through.
I also then told
you about habits.
And actually, the last
chapter of the book
is about protecting
yourself from yourself.
Because we all have
pretty bad habits.
We actually asked our users to
confess, and on Good Morning
America tomorrow I'm
sharing some confessions
from some of their users.
Good Morning America
had them call in.
So one, we teach you
really good habits.
I log in, as I said.
To my LearnVest account
once a day, for a minute,
just to see and track
and see what's going on.
But I do spend.
January, I sit down
and we go through
and really make sure we
have a complete plan.
And guys, it's like
anything else in your life.
If you have a plan,
you will do more.
If your goals are set, which we
actually write your goals down
in the LearnVest platform,
so they're there.
And then you can expert
that checks in with you.
And then you get
awesome benefits
that are like little
surprises, once you
start achieving them from us.
And the takeaway there
is, writing things down,
having some hold
you accountable.
That's how you end up
really making progress.
And so it's not eight-- I
think eight hours a month
is a lot, to be honest.
As an expert who like is a
total geek for this stuff,
I don't spend eight
hours a month.
But some months, maybe
I will spend eight.
Some months I spend 12.
I mean it depends
one, what's going on.
And then, just so
you guys know, if you
want me to sign your books,
I'm going to sit up here,
so we'll go through any of that.
Did you have another question?
AUDIENCE: OK, yes.
What do you think
of Lending Club
as a vehicle for investment?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
I just think that if
you're in a position where
you have like an extra
million sitting around,
then I would be like,
maybe something like that
could make sense.
But the truth is,
of all the things
you could be doing
with your money,
I would put that as probably
lower on the priority list.
They of course, are
like-- they actually
were shut down by the
SEC for a full year.
Yeah, they had a
bunch of problems.
And I'm not saying that
they're like risky today,
but what I am saying is,
I think that it's probably
not your highest priority.
I think there's
probably safer things
to be doing with your money.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So, I'm curious what
your thoughts are
on paying your
mortgage down early,
versus taking that money
and kind of putting it
somewhere else.
Because obviously with
your mortgage payment,
you have interest deductions,
all these other things
like tie into it.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
So again, what we
would do is, literally
run what's going on in your
life through the system.
And you can actually
see, it's based
on what's going on with
your interest rate.
What other things that
are-- interest rates
that your juggling.
And potentially,
the answer is yes.
Potentially the answer
may be, you know what?
That extra cash is going
to be much better served
doing this next
goal that you have,
because that mortgage
isn't bad for you.
So it really depends on who
you are, where you're going.
Do you want to sell your house
in this period of time or not,
etc.
So.
Great question but the answer
there is, run a financial plan,
and it tells you perfectly.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So, I understand
that financial planners
don't sell us anything right?
But do they make specific
product recommendations?
So let's say I need life
insurance, or investments,
mutual funds.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So literally,
our financial planners
are all full time
on staff for us.
They're salaried by us.
Their bonus is only based on
customer satisfaction, customer
results, period.
And efficiency of
getting back to you.
That's it.
So that's how they
get compensated.
Let's just say that you
come in and you're like,
I need life insurance.
Just, let's use
that as an example.
AUDIENCE: Right.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: We would
go through and figure out
what is actually best for you.
Hey, you do need
a million of term.
That's what you can afford.
That's the best thing
that we can do for you.
We don't sell it.
We will then make a
recommendation that
looks like this,
we like MassMutual
for this specific
product that you need.
And we also like Guardian,
and we also like Prudential.
And then will help you
go and look at those,
and then you can get quotes.
Or we'll connect you to an
agent who can then get quotes.
We will not get a single
dollar in that recommendation.
Zero.
It's one of our pillars
of our company's policy
of being trusted and
unbiased for our customers.
AUDIENCE: Right but
I still may need
to go to an agent who would
get a commission on it.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: You
will go to an agent
and they still will
get a commission on it.
That's correct.
But the takeaway there is
you won't be in a position
where you go to that agent, and
end up getting too much, or too
little because you
don't trust them,
and you don't know what
you're supposed to be doing.
And one of the things that
we're in the middle of piloting
is actually us doing it
for you, and you paying us
a simple fee of like $100,
and we'll go get it for you.
But we are just
piloting that right now.
So that we'd just say,
let us do it for you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: You're welcome.
Go ahead.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: I just had--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: And by the
way, thanks guys for, I mean,
this stuff everyone
really needs help.
And so, I'm always
never surprised
by how many questions
people have.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Do have any
recourse if you go to a CFP
and you get bad advice?
Like factually incorrect
things, or they
advise you to do something
and it turns out not to work?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So--
AUDIENCE: I'm not talking
about like telling the future
with like stock market
or anything like that.
I mean.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
I mean, so first, I'd would be
like, were they actually a CFP?
So let me just give
you an example.
I worked at Morgan Stanley.
A lot of times, they
just have people
who are just well educated.
They're actually only licensed
by like a series seven,
and they like, will give advice,
but they're actually just
managing investments,
if that makes sense.
So like, a lot of people
go and get advice,
and they'll just manage
your investments.
But none of that other
stuff, which is actually
step one for what
you should be doing.
So the takeaway there is,
I would first be like,
were they even an
expert to begin with.
If they work for a
reputable company that
reports to the SEC,
you can complain.
And you can write a complaint
that then goes on their record.
We personally will
never hire anyone
with even a single complaint.
Done.
Get outta here.
We're not hiring you.
So I think that's
the sort of stuff.
So the answer is,
the recourse is
that you can file a
complaint on their record.
But, I would then,
a lot of people
get advice from people
that are not experts.
Because it's really complicated.
Like, you don't even know
who really an expert is.
So that's why we say, we
really believe in the CFP.
There are 69,000 in the
country, and I'm even
on one of their boards.
That's like how deep
we are with the CFP.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Good question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You described
your automated system that
tells you should do this,
and this, and this, and that.
And I've found
with other systems
that they are often
very inflexible.
Like, they would make
assumptions like, oh, customers
should not have to deal
with single stocks.
They should always
use mutual funds.
Or customers are generally not
able to control themselves.
How much they spend.
So we assume they always over
spend, or something like that.
And so I find these
systems fairly useless,
because they don't adjust
to my own personal habits.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yep.
So, a few things.
AUDIENCE: How's your
system handling that?
ALEXA VON TOBEL:
So actually, what's
really cool about our system,
and this is like super dorky,
but just to give you a sense.
There's actually behind the
system, is 44 standards.
They're literally
the 44 standards
of every single person's life.
It's not in the book actually.
We took it out because it
like overwhelmed people.
But there's actually a grid.
And it literally, for
each step, there's
basically 15 things
that are critical.
And when you get a
plan, we actually
will circle what's urgent,
so that you are aware of,
here are the things.
But that's when you then get
on the phone with your expert,
and when we're
delivering a plan.
And so it happens
in the sign up flow,
when you're actually
filling out the form.
But then also, on
the first call,
we call it the listening call.
Where you say,
here are the things
that I like that I want to do.
We'll then tell you, hey,
maybe you want single stocks.
We don't like them
for these reasons.
You now know.
But if that's what you
want to do, we'll help you.
But we'll tell you
it's like really
damaging for your finances.
You know, some people walk
in and they're like, I really
like to bury money my backyard.
And we're like, I
get that you love
that, we don't recommend that.
And so, there's a little
bit of like a process.
But you get to weigh in
on what you care about.
And also, we help
you ultimately work
on what you want to work on.
But if there's something
that is really critical,
we're like you are at risk.
And then, you can
either do it or not.
We strongly recommend you do it.
We try to hold you accountable.
But at the end of the day,
we don't force you to do it.
AUDIENCE: So once I tell my
adviser on the phone that I
really--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So it's
a very flexible schedule.
So the takeaway--
AUDIENCE: So that I
really want to bury
my money in the
backyard, is your system
able to deal with that?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yes.
The takeaway is, the
system literally, is built.
There's 44 standards,
and they can move around
based on what the
customer wants.
There's also a few
filters where it's
like, this customer's
really overwhelmed.
So let's give him slower goals.
This customer's a champ.
I walk in, I'm like, let's
go tell me everything.
I want to know it.
I want to see it.
But it depends on,
and you can decide.
So you actually, it's very
much built around who you are.
And that's actually
one of the things
that's a requirement
of LearnVest.
You have to know your
customer to a law.
You have to know your customer.
How they want to act.
What they care about.
And that form you
fill out, is actually,
it's not just like us being
like, we'd love to know.
We actually legally need
to know what you care about
and how you want to operate.
So.
AUDIENCE: A different question
that just came to my mind.
There was the previous
question about privacy,
and you said you don't
have any account numbers
and stuff, right?
But you do link
into our account so
that we can see our
balance in your system.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: But it doesn't
pull your account number.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
get my information if you
don't-- without having
all my bank information?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So
it's as simple as this.
Let's just say you're
linking your bank.
You literally, to
link it, all you do
and it takes less
than about 45 seconds.
You go, Fidelity, my
username, my password, boom.
And it pulls in just
the information.
The data.
It's not pulling in your account
number, your routing number.
It's not pulling in all
of that information.
But we can see at the
transaction level,
so you can see--
AUDIENCE: But you would have
my username and my password.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: We have your
username and your password.
But we don't store your
username and password.
It's just like Mint.
It's just like Quicken Books.
It's just like--
AUDIENCE: I don't
know these products.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But don't you update
that information all the time?
ALEXA VON TOBEL:
Every time you log in.
It just pulls it.
AUDIENCE: But then I have to
type in my other passwords
all the time?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: No.
Once they're linked
their linked.
And that connection's there.
And every time you log in,
we refresh the latest data
from the last 30 day--
the last 90 days.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: And if you
had an account for like, me
from the beginning, we
store all your trends
from literally day one.
And you can see it all.
It's really amazing actually.
I, living in New York,
restaurant and bars,
I'm like, I live at my company.
Right?
Like I literally like can't
cook, because I'm just working.
And so it was like,
I never knew what
I was spending on
restaurant and bars.
And quickly it was
like, oh my goodness.
I can see exactly, and it's
much worse than I thought.
So we can pull those
trends and analysis.
But when you log
in, you don't have
to re insert your
username and password.
It's one time and then it pulls.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: You're welcome.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I am getting married this
year and I was wondering--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Congrats.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: I
got married this year.
AUDIENCE: Huh?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: I
got married in 2013
AUDIENCE: Oh good.
Yes.
So I was wondering,
if I sign up for this,
and then my fiance also
signs up, can we merge?
ALEXA VON TOBEL:
It's per household.
It's just you guys.
Both of you.
One account.
AUDIENCE: So we can go--
ALEXA VON TOBEL:
My husband and I
have a plan, even though
I'm the CEO and a CFP
and wrote this book.
We have a second set of eyes
looking at what we're doing.
AUDIENCE: Even if our bank
accounts aren't joined yet?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
Totally fine.
AUDIENCE: We can sign up
under the same account?
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yep.
It's your household.
AUDIENCE: And you guys would
work with us as far as--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: You can
both get on the phone.
Sometimes my husband
doesn't get on the phone
because he has to miss it.
I get on it, he can get on it.
And actually, to be honest,
I've been giving it--
so we like literally
see it gifted as a baby
gift, a wedding gift.
We see kids giving
it to their parents,
parents giving it to their kids.
Last night people bought like
10 plans for their friends.
I mean, it's really amazing
how often it's gifted.
But particularly for a wedding,
it's such a critical time.
Like you're dealing
with all that stuff.
Our experts are experts at that.
And so you both--
and it's one-- you
don't have to buy
two plans, just one.
And also, if your life changes.
Let's say tomorrow, you're
like, we're having a baby!
We don't make you re-buy a plan.
We just rerun your information.
And be like, hey you now
have a different goal.
And so that's why it's
like a gym membership.
You pay the up front
fee, it's $19 a month,
it's always the same expert.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Cool.
Do you have another question?
Wow.
Awesome guys.
And guys, keep me
honest Annie for when
I know I have to go
to the other Google.
And guys, page 11 is your
dedicated promo code.
Use it.
And if you guys get a plan,
I'm just going to say,
Annie's email address
is a-n-n-i-e@LearnVest.
If you buy a plan today,
and just shoot us a note,
we'll get you an extra
free month of service.
So another free month of $19.
That's just a
benefit for you guys.
AUDIENCE: One of the biggest
parts of any financial planning
is taxes.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yep.
Income tax planning is actually
six pillars of-- the CFP
is six pillars.
Income tax planning, insurance
planning, investment planning,
retirement planning, general
principles, and then,
what did I miss?
Estate planning.
Estate planning was biatch.
So, our experts are
experts in all six.
AUDIENCE: So we just
learned this, actually.
The advisors actually give
like tax planning advice and--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So as
part of-- so, so, let me
give you an example.
If you have like,
over $5 million,
and you're in a
position where like,
you have pretty complex
income tax planning,
we would actually
go and recommend
that you do that with
an income tax expert.
However, most people.
Your income tax
planning is actually
just the basics of
financial planning.
And so yes.
You do get basic income
tax planning advice.
But if you're someone who's
like, owns five properties,
like, we're like,
you've complexity
that is beyond a normal plan.
Let's go get that.
Estate planning was actually
the pillar called protect.
So we include that in insurance
and estate, is pillar five.
And we do give basic
estate planning advice.
Because that's things
like, simple things guys
like TOD and P-- stuff
that you wouldn't even
know to know about.
It's really basic
things that you can just
do on your account, wherever it
may be, to protect, God forbid,
anything happens.
AUDIENCE: So that
includes things
like setting up trusts and--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So if you're
setting up a basic trust,
that's the type of thing our
expert can talk to you about.
If you're setting up
some very complex trust,
depending on again, and one of
the takeaways that we say is,
we have customers who
have millions of dollars,
and that we can give really
great advice to and service.
But we would look at how complex
you are, what's going on.
And if it's something that
if you're in that situation,
and it's so beyond,
we would say,
here's an estate planner that
we really like, that we trust,
work with them.
AUDIENCE: I see.
OK.
Thank you.
ALEXA VON TOBEL:
Any other questions?
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I have a
follow up to his question.
Now, in your answer
it sounded like you're
giving advice for income tax.
You're giving advice
for estate planning.
But you're not actually doing
the estate planning with me,
do you?
I mean I'd still need to get
the forms from somewhere else,
and still need to fill them
out myself, and still need
to file them myself.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: So here's,
I'll give you an example.
So first, the
income tax planning
is actually part of
actually making a plan.
So I'll give you an example.
When I recommend a Roth
IRA versus a regular IRA,
that's actually a little
bit of income tax planning.
Because based on which
one you should get,
is based on what your
income is and what
your tax bracket will be.
So that's part of the plan.
Just in general.
Income tax planning is sort
of a pillar of all planning.
If you're in a position
where it's like,
you're making $1.5
million and we could maybe
help shepherd some of that
so you could afford taxes
in like a thoughtful
planning way.
That's like, high level
income tax planning.
So just in general, income tax
planning is part of every plan.
And then for things
like documents.
So we actually get a
discount at LegalZoom.
We like them a lot, because
they make it really affordable.
A lot of people go
get wills and end up
spending $1,000 to do it.
And we're like, you can get just
as good of a will doing this.
But we'll show you exactly
which one you need,
exactly how to fill it out.
And then one thing that
confidentially we're
rolling out is as part of
getting a plan with us,
were also starting
to offer classes.
So detailed, step by step.
If you're like, how
do I fill out my will?
Literally, here's exactly,
those sort of things.
How do I deal with
getting a mortgage?
Or refinancing my mortgage?
Step by step.
That's the sort of
content that we're
creating so you can just like,
attend a quick 30 minute class,
or download a webinar.
We show you exactly
how to do it.
AUDIENCE: And come tax season,
right now basically, I still
need to get my own CPA
or do you have to--
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Yeah.
We do not do your taxes.
But we help you prepare for what
you need to do, and tell you
what you need to do.
But we don't actually
file them for you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Just separate
types of financial planning.
Any other questions?
OK.
Great.
So Annie, a-n-n-i-e, if
anyone wants to get a plan,
we'll give you an
extra month of service.
If anyone wants me to sign a
book while I'm walking out,
I'm happy to do that.
And page 11 is your
unique $50 promo code.
Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEXA VON TOBEL: Thanks guys.
Annie, do you have some pens?